Aún falta un año para las elecciones
pero la carrera para suceder a Andrés
Manuel López Obrador en la presidencia
mexicana empieza a tomar forma hoy estoy
presentando mi renuncia porque estamos
resueltos a participar el día de ayer
estuvimos en el Consejo Nacional Aquí no
hay planes de El plan a es ganar y
vencer al anuncio del canciller Marcelo
ebrard se sumó la alcaldesa de Ciudad de
México Claudia sheinbaum que lidera las
primeras encuestas
que he tomado la decisión
de separarme del cargo de forma
definitiva
el 16 de junio del presente
con el fin de llegar a ser la primera
mujer en la historia de México
el encabezar los destinos de la
naturaleza
junto a Brad y sheinbaum también
competirán el líder oficialista en el
senado Ricardo Monreal quien anunció que
dejará el cargo el próximo viernes y el
ministro del interior Adán Augusto López
que todavía debe oficializar su salida
morena pautó reglas claras para todos
los precandidatos para competir en la
interna tienen que dejar sus puestos en
el estado esta semana y la disputa
deberá ser Leal No puede haber
denostación entre compañeros tiene que
haber absoluto respeto y tampoco pueden
pues hablar mal o desacreditar a este
proceso porque tiene todo el consenso
del Consejo Nacional a la lista de
contendientes pueden sumarse el senador
Manuel Velasco y Gerardo Fernández
Noroña si el partido verde y los
laboristas lo aprueban morena que
favorita para las generales de 2024
acordó que el 6 de septiembre se
anunciará el ganador tras el proceso de